cette photo du Che Guevara vous la
connaissez tous elle a été imprimée sur
des millions de t-shirts elle a été
prise il y a tout juste 63 ans ça fait
longtemps et pourtant elle reste un
objet culte comme cette photo d'autres
clichés sont devenus
iconiques avec le temps le portrait
d'Albert Einstein la photo de Marilyn
Monroe au-dessus d'une bouche de métro
le déjeuner en haut d'un gratte-ciel ou
encore la photo de cette jeune afgane
aux yeux verts toutes ces photos ont une
histoire que nous allons vous raconter
avec Lorraine Malka Lauren vient de
rejoindre la team épicurieux elle adore
la pop culture et vous allez le voir il
a le don de dénicher des infos
surprenantes on commence tout de suite
avec la photo du Che
[Musique]
cette photo d'Alberto Corda est la
deuxième image la plus reproduite de
l'art occidentale après
la Joconde et dire qu'elle est restée
dans les tiroirs du photographe pendant
presque 7 ans et surtout qu'elle ne lui
a jamais rien rapporté pas un sou voilà
son histoire
nous sommes le 5 mars 1960 à La Havane
la veille un cargo chargé de munition
pour Cuba à exploser dans le port de La
Havane bilan presque sans mort pour le
président Fidel Castro aucun doute c'est
un coût de la CIA il décide donc de
faire un discours pour rendre hommage
aux victimes à quelques mètres de lui en
tribune se trouve Alberto Corda chargé
de le photographier mais toujours à
l'affût le photographe repère Che
Guevara qui s'approche de la balustrade
pour contempler la foule ni une ni deux
Corda a juste le temps d'appuyer deux
fois sur son appareil avant que le Chey
ne disparaisse l'instant dure moins de
30 secondes il présente les photos à son
journal mais celle du Chey n'est pas
retenu il faut attendre le mois de juin
1967 pour qu'un éditeur italien janjako
morelinelli tombe sur le sésame il
demande son prix à Corda cadeau lui
répond le photographe l'Italien qui est
un homme d'affaire très futé embarque le
tirage et le transforme en poster non
signé qu'ils vont 5 dollars pièces et là
c'est bingo
en effet quelques mois plus tard le
Shemer assassiné par balle en Bolivie la
photo de Corda fait alors la Une des
plus grands journaux du monde la photo
est même imprimée sur les t-shirts on en
fait des tirages posters qui se vendent
comme des petits pains le cliché et même
sérigraphié par Andy Warhol mais plus
incroyable dans tout ça c'est que jamais
son auteur ne réclamera le moindre
centime Alberto Corda meurt en 2001 sans
regret pour lui ce cliché n'était comme
il le disait lui-même qui a coup de
chance deuxième photo je l'adore
celle-ci venez
c'est la photo la plus célèbre d'Albert
Einstein je suis sûr que vous la
connaissez mais peut-être pas son
histoire 14 mars 1951 Einstein vient de
fêter ses 72 ans dans le New Jersey il
est tard il veut rentrer mais c'est déjà
une icône à l'époque une horde de
journaliste l'attend à la sortie pour le
photographier il rejoint ses copains
dans une voiture affiche un air ronchon
pour qu'on arrête de le paparazier
jusqu'au moment où l'un des photographes
Arthur SAS lui crie un dernier sourire
pour votre anniversaire monsieur
Einstein agacé Einstein le regard droit
dans les yeux et lui tire la langue la
photo est exceptionnelle mais à l'agence
on hésite à la publier on a peur de
vexer le grand génie finalement l'image
est envoyée à la presse et se retrouve
en Une de François Albert Einstein n'en
tiendra pas rigueur photographe et à la
presse il adorait l'autodérision
et puis derrière ce geste il y a un vrai
message qu'il va lui-même décrypter j'ai
toujours eu de la difficulté écrite il a
accepter l'autorité et ici tirer la
langue à un photographe qui s'attend à
une peau solennelle cela signifie que
l'on refuse de se prêter au jeu de la
représentation point à la ligne c'est
acte de rébellion n'empêchera pas Albert
Einstein d'en commander 9 copies à
Arthur SAS il en dédicacera même un
exemplaire à un ami journaliste qui sera
ensuite vendu aux enchères au prix tenez
vous bien de
74324 dollars preuve qu'une belle
grimace vaut parfois plus qu'un joli
sourire
pas mal enfin tout est relatif allez
suivante
déjeuner en haut d'un gratte-ciel c'est
le titre de cette photo culte qui
représente des ouvriers américains
cassant la coupe ils ont l'air de se
détendre comme au comptoir d'un bistrot
alors qu'ils sont assis sur une poutre
qui surplombe Manhattan sans aucune
sécurité à plus de 240 mètres au-dessus
du sol s'agit-il d'un simple trucage pas
du tout ce cliché a été pris le 20
septembre 1932 pendant la construction
du célèbre rock Fellers Center les
ouvriers sont de vrais ouvriers qui
travaillent sur le chantier par contre
il s'agit d'une mise en scène on a
demandé à ses 11 maçons de sourire et de
prendre la pose pour une publicité qui
paraîtra dans le New York et raltribu
l'objectif vendre des espaces de bureau
dans ce building mais ce qui est encore
plus vertigineux c'est le contexte
historique de ce cliché nous sommes au
lendemain du krach boursier de 1929 une
période de crise sociale et économique
sans précédent aux États-Unis on appelle
cette période la Grande Dépression en
fait le milliardaire John Rockefeller
qui construit ce complexe culturel et
commercial veut faire rêver les
Américains et il entend le montrer avec
une image de travailleur heureux de
bâtir la future capitale du monde sauf
que la réalité est beaucoup plus sombre
les 11 hommes présents sur l'image font
partie des 4000 ouvriers payés 1 dollar
50 de l'heure par le milliardaire c'est
un salaire de misère pour l'époque mais
ils n'ont pas le choix ils préfèrent
risquer leur vie plutôt que de pointer
au chômage pour info il faut savoir
qu'un ouvrier sur 10 en moyenne
effectuait une chute mortelle par
tranche de 10 étages on a retrouvé le
nom de certains d'entre eux Sonic maty
ochanocy Joseph heptner Joker this pour
la plupart ce sont des Irlandais
immigrés aujourd'hui les New Yorkais
considèrent que ces hommes font partie
de leur propre famille allez photo
suivante
Marilyn Monroe est une icône
intemporelle c'est en partie à travers
cette photo je devrais plutôt dire à
travers ses photos car elle n'est pas
unique il en existe des dizaines prises
le même jour par une foule de
photographe elles ont été prises en
septembre 1954 à New York l'actrice qui
tourne le film de Billy Wilder cet Andre
réflexion avant le tournage Billy Wilder
fait appel au photographe Sam show pour
créer l'esthétique du film à la lecture
du scénario se repère une scène dans
laquelle Maryline se promène dans la rue
et marche au-dessus d'une grille de
métro qui soulève sa robe blanche ce
sera l'affiche du film dit-il histoire
de faire le buzz le photographe organise
alors à New York un faux tournage de la
fameuse scène auquel il convie toute la
presse plusieurs centaines de
journalistes des photographes et des
fans de Maryline sont au rendez-vous
pour voir la robe de Marilyn s'envoler
au dessus de la soufflerie les
photographes présents ce soir-là sont
tous convaincus qu'ils ont accès aux
coulisses d'un tournage historique dès
le lendemain les photos sont publiées à
la une de tous les magazines l'histoire
aurait pu s'arrêter là mais vous allez
le voir cet épisode va avoir des
répercussions inattendues dans la vie de
Marilyn Monroe ce doutant du battage
médiatique que va faire cette photo
plutôt
osé pour l'époque la robe s'élève
au-dessus des jeunots de la star Joe son
mari entre dans une colère noire et
frappe violemment Marylin au visage
c'est maquilleuse racontera plus tard
qu'il lui fallut des heures pour
camoufler les traces de coups d'imago ne
sera pas poursuivi à cette époque
malheureusement les violences faites aux
femmes ne sont pas un sujet mais
Maryline blessée au sens propre comme au
sens figuré sera sans pitié avec lui
elle le quitte peu de temps après et
décide de voler de ses propres ailes en
créant sa propre compagnie de production
allez dernière photo
celle-ci vous avez vu ce regard
hypnotisant prise en 1984 par le
photographe américain Steve McCurry
cette photo qu'on appelle l'afghane aux
yeux verts ou la jeune Afghane fait la
couverture du magazine National
Geographic l'année suivante et on peut
le dire elle va bouleverser le monde
suite à sa parution des millions de
personnes se portent volontaires pour
travailler dans des camps de réfugiés la
jeune fille est âgée de 13 ans quand
Steve McCurry la découvre dans une école
de fille située dans un camp de réfugiés
afghan à péchaouar au Pakistan il la
sent plus timide que les autres mais il
réussit à la photographie une fois
rentré à New York le photographe est
saisi par la force de l'image un regard
intense et égaré dit l'histoire aurait
pu s'arrêter là mais Steve McCurry
conscient de l'impact qu'a eu ce regard
sur des millions de personnes à travers
le monde décident de retrouver son
modèle il ne connaît pas son nom il va
donc chercher pendant des années et puis
en 2002 il retrouve enfin sa trace elle
vit dans l'une des régions les plus
dangereuses d'Afghanistan
elle s'appelle charbat Goula ce qui veut
dire fille fleur d'eau douce en
Pacheteau l'une des langues officielles
du pays elle ne sait rien de sa
notoriété et franchement c'est le cadet
de ces soucis elle vit recluse avec son
mari et ses filles dans une très grande
pauvreté ce n'est qu'en 2021 que Sharbat
Goula comprend à quel point cette photo
peut changer sa vie celle de ses filles
et peut-être même celle d'autres enfants
réfugiés aujourd'hui à plus de 50 ans
après avoir reçu des propositions d'aide
de différents gouvernements elle a
décidé de poursuivre sa vie en Italie ou
ses filles sont libres d'aller à l'école
un nouveau chapitre espérons-le pour une
vie plus douce merci Lorraine comment
une simple photo peut changer notre
regard sur le monde c'est toute la force
de ce mode d'expression si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à nous
proposer en commentaire d'autres photos
iconiques nous vous en révélerons les
coulisses et si bien sûr vous avez
flashé sur celle du jour lâchez-vous
likez et abonnez-vous
c'est pas déjà fait allez à dimanche
prochain chers épicurieuses et
épicurieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]